uh the boys yep this is exciting
you grew a beard you're playing soldier
boy i did not know i could grow a beard
like that boy you grew a beard man yeah
that sucker was that pisses me off when
i see a perfect beard
[ __ ] i have this waffle beard i
had more products
for the for the for the
the beast on my face than i had for any
other part of my body they they
conditioned your beard i had well i mean
yeah i had you got to get the you got to
get the shampoo that's special for beard
you got to get the conditioner that's
special for beard you got to get the
beard bomb there's beard butter there's
uh there there's the wax there's the oil
i mean i it was like i i didn't know
this is my first time into this world so
i'm just buying different ones and
trying different ones i had a whole side
of my my bathroom was taken over by
beard [ __ ]
and you had the beard for the entire run
no no they um
they
so what happens is i don't think this is
any secret i'm not getting anything away
uh
they they kind of
find me
um and i've been essentially in
captivity for a while
and so when they do i'm
bearded and i look like castaway uh but
then they uh
um then they clean me up and i get my
superhero outfit back on and i i go to
town now essentially the show is
superheroes are celebrities controlled
by a corporation and they're not good
people ultimately is that right right
and so i'm guessing or do you not want
to give it away
that you're playing a character that's
not really that good of a guy no he's
he's a he's a jackass he's a jackass
yeah and it's like a captain america
kind of character it is yeah so
it's dark because ryan you were saying
how bloody it is oh my god cause i'm
gonna watch it now that you're in it oh
bro i heard it's great anyway you'll
love it yeah they just got uh nominated
for emmy for best drama jesus yeah up
against uh i didn't want to watch that
the crown and bridgeton and this is us
because i hear that there's some dark
[ __ ] on this this had to be very
exciting for you to kind of like uh
it is it's great i was a fan of the show
before uh we even talked about me coming
on um and in fact the whole way that
happened was
i was calling eric kripke who is the
show runner in the boys right who also
created supernatural right and i i was
calling him to talk to him about the
winchesters
and at the end of our conversation
because i had because he he owns that ip
right because he created those
characters so i literally had to call
him and get
him to sign off now now they kicked it
over to business affairs at warner
brothers and his lawyers and they got
together and they
you know they did their thing but uh but
i need to get kripke to sign off on us
using those characters for this this uh
this prequel
and in in that conversation at the end
of that conversation
i said well hey man supernaturals uh
we're wrapping up here um
or it's or it's gonna be wrapped up uh
because we were this was during the
break when we broke
for covid and it was before we came back
to shoot our our last two episodes
and uh i was like i'm gonna be
unemployed pretty soon so whenever
you're ready for me to come on over to
the boys just let me know and he was
like hey man if you want to come over to
the boys i'll i'll
i'll write you a part
just like that i got no problem with
that and i'm like yeah dude i'd love to
come over there quiet it's like i love
that show and he goes
well hang on he's like
i don't know if he's like
i don't know if i want to bring in for
just like a bit part
he's like there's another role
i'll tell you what i'm going to send you
over some material take a look at it
let's talk tomorrow i was like okay so
he sends me over soldier boy
and i read that i read this this
material and i was like
yes
absolutely what made you say yes who do
i have to kill right what was it about
the soldier boy character that you like
had to do it he was he's this
uh
i mean he's a he's a grandpa right he's
from the 40s like he fought in world war
ii
and he's he's just this curmudgeon
bigoted
[ __ ]
and he's you know he doesn't age so he's
this young
or this this you know 40 year old
superhero
uh who's really 80 years old or 90 years
old
and there's there's just so much
material there and you'll see what i
mean when you see that when you see the
the show but um you know he just he has
uh he's a taste for for people that were
of his
of his era
right um
and
so it was uh it was a no-brainer but
again
this was something that the studio that
sony was talking to some much bigger
names than me
and uh and wanted to bring in for season
three and so eric was like look
i i know you can do this he's like but
we're gonna have to convince
the the you know the powers and how did
you convince them so
did you read he's like you're going to
put yourself on tape and i was like
great
i'll do that
so i did
and i sent it to him only
and then he noted me of course i did it
again said it to him he noted me again
yeah we did we went back and forth about
four times and he was like okay he's
like i'm i'm cool if you're cool like i
can take this up the up the chain here
and
uh see what kind of response we get i
was like
look if you're going to go to bat for me
i want to give you the biggest bat i can
right
um so tell me if there's anything else i
can do he's like you're good
and so he went to bat for me and then
boom that was it but i i work for it it
wasn't just like hey we want to bring
you on for season three right no i had
to earn this one you have to earn a lot
i think people think that you know a lot
of things are given to you no and you
have to fight for them and this is how i
had to do it this is interesting you
know uh you know the show right yeah so
the audition scene that i had to do was
a scene with soldier boy and butcher
played by carl urban carl i saw you
golfing with him on instagram good guy
um good good new zealand boy will he
come on the podcast carl yeah if you can
dig him up from down under
you